when I was six years old my family went
camping on the beach in the effort to
teach us kids what it meant to be Native
Hawaiian we would gather in tide pools
we cut fish we learned how to cook them
and played games and in the evening our
uncle a very loving and kind man named
mr. ko Noah would tell us stories about
our ancestors so one night he gathered
us together in a circle and he told us
about these great navigators who sailed
on these little canoes across the
world's largest ocean using the Stars
and the Sun and the moon to guide them
to find tiny little islands scattered
across this great expanse the stories
were awesome and we were hooked but mr.
Kona could see in our eyes that he could
have been talking about the Trojans or
the Vikings because to us there's really
no difference those people that he was
talking about in those stories seemed
kind of distant sort of abstract to
belong to us
to me so he asked us everybody stand up
so we did he said each one of you are
descended from somebody like that in one
of those stories and lined up behind
each one of us are members of our entire
family who came before that if we ever
fall they'll be right there to catch you
and if you're lucky really lucky and you
walk slowly ever so slowly and then
quickly look back you just might see one
of them out of the corner of your eye
try it okay so we started walking kind
of awkwardly slowly ever so slowly we
quickly turn back in anticipation did
you see them yeah well what did they
look like Oh mine was seven feet tall
with big muscles
said one of the show-off boys my best
friend she said hers had beautiful skin
with long black hair I didn't say
anything but I was sure that I saw my
great-great-grandmother in a tenth of a
dress her silver hair pulled back
looking at me with a stern but approving
look looking into her eyes it was like
looking into my own in the mirror at
that moment for the rest of my life
I knew that my ancestors were real that
everywhere I went no matter how much
trouble I was in no matter how lonely I
felt they would be right there with me
to help but why am I talking about
ancestors because we all have them and
whether we're aware of it or not they
have the power to affect profoundly our
lives our ancestors we are of them and
they are in us most of us recognize that
right in our physical traits kind of
family resemblances like I have my
mother's eyes or maybe in mannerisms I'm
not sure where I get that from but
scientists are discovering through a new
field called behavioral epigenetics that
not only do we get these physical traits
passed down but the experiences and
actions of our ancestors get passed to
us as memory through tiny little
switches in our DNA so in other words
our experiences they get stored in our
genes they become part of us and then we
pass them down to our offspring so for
example victims of trauma you know
poverty war childhood abuse they carry
around that trauma not just as memories
but in molecular scars so that handsome
chin of yours that chiseled went from
your grandfather may not be the only
thing you inherited from him you may
have also inherited his predisposition
to depression based on something he
suffered but the good news is not only
do kind of our deficits and our
mrs. get passed down but so do our
strengths and our resilience is we
inherit loving behavior we inherit
kindness we inherit positive outlooks so
that eternal optimism that you have that
ability to overcome to persevere likely
came from somebody in your family line
who overcame something and then passed
those awesome traits unto you so I
started thinking what kind of ancestor
do I want to be what kind of negative
things am i carrying around some traits
that or things that I'm creating that I
don't want to pass on conversely what
are those positive things those awesome
traits or those things I have yet to
create that I want to make sure that I
do some of those people those survivors
they did that they made choices to
profoundly change the future of their
families by kind of overriding those
junk and creating new memories to create
a new path and we can do that too
but it gets better much more interesting
so now we'll need to be pass all this
stuff down through our DNA but our
ancestors can actually also help us
perform better a study recently by the
European Journal of Social Psychology
showed that simply thinking about our
genetic origin helps us perform better
so I thought about that and I thought in
these studies you know these people did
puzzles or they ran obstacle courses and
just being triggered to think about
their ancestor they did better and you
know that's happened to me so earlier in
my career I was a diver I used to go in
these small little inflatable boats to
remote islands in the Pacific and study
coral reefs and on my very first trip I
was terrified 1,200 miles away from
safety and I knew that in every place we
were gonna explore we were probably
gonna encounter sharks but I came from
ocean people remember those guys and
those tiny canoes that sailed across
that huge ocean yeah when I thought
about that and I remembered that my fear
went away I don't mean to sound
dramatics I know that kind of does but
really it was incredible even to me how
I could do things
that I had never done before simply by
drawing on their courage and their
ancient wisdom of the sea thinking about
them gave me the confidence to perform
better and then kind of drawing from
their memory and their experience I
figured out how it's pretty it's pretty
powerful so we all have relatively
complex brains right so imagine what
ancestral wisdom like that is stored up
in you from the thousands of years since
your ancestors were born talk about Big
Data imagine if we could tap into that
ancestral databank to help us make
better choices now to help us perform
better we only get one chance at this
thing called life right so all of those
choices and the way we perform that
tells us what we're going to leave for
the future so now that we know that even
if we don't know who those ancestors are
we carry their wisdom and their strength
with us
what kind of ancestors do we together
wanna be to leave society better so we
start off as descendants of our
ancestors in life but at some point
either directly or indirectly we end up
as ancestors of our descendants our
choices our decisions are going to
affect what happens in future
generations this idea became kind of
came home to me on the birth of my first
son coming all when he was born my
journey to become an ancestor had begun
it had become my legacy to think about
his so when I think about looking back
now I don't just look back for me I have
to look back and ask how to help me to
help him a couple weeks ago my middle
son eye Lama was playing on a courtyard
and the courtyard right here in campus
and he was kind of looking back and
talking to someone so I thought he was
playing ninjas or pirates one of the
imaginary places he loves to go and I
said hey who are you this time he said
no one mama as he looked at his shoes
I was just having a hard day so I've
turned around to see who was there help
I don't even remember telling my son
that story in fact I'm not even sure I
ever did but I can't tell you how much
peace that gives me as a mother to know
that even when I'm not there to protect
my son
to give him guidance that he knows his
ancestors are real and that if he ever
needs them he just has to turn around
ancestors we all have them I encourage
you to tap into your ancestral bank say
honor those who came before to think
about how to do awesome now and to leave
a super great future for those to follow
ask yourself what kind of ancestor do
you want to be thank you very much